aux etats unis toujours un nouveau
rebondissement dans l affaire qui oppose
des plaignants à l'agencé américaine des
médicaments une organisation avait saisi
la justice pour demander la publication
des données du vaccin fazer l'île en
teck après avoir réclamé des dizaines
d'années de délai la fda est désormais
sommé d' accélérer sa publication les
détails avec notre correspondant à
washington thomas boni ce juge considère
que les données ayant mené à
l'approbation du vaccin pfizer aux états
unis sont d'une importance capitale et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il estime
je cite leurs publications nécessaire
alors pour rappel la f10 l agence
américaine des médicaments avait proposé
un rythme de publication de 500 pages
par mois ce qui aurait voulu dire que
pour avoir accès à l'intégralité des
données ayant mené à l'approbation du
vaccin blazers aux états unis il aurait
fallu attendre
2096 et bien ce tribunal fixe un autre
rythme cinquante cinq mille pages publié
chaque mois ce tribunal demande aussi
que le caviardage qui consiste à rendre
confidentiels certains passages de ces
données ne soit réalisé que si cela est
strictement nécessaire évidemment cette
décision a été saluée par les plaignants
il s'agit d'une organisation militant
pour la transparence en matière de santé
publique et cette organisation à s'était
offusqué il ya quelques semaines du
délai si l'on proposé par la f10 est
alors que cette même agence avait validé
le vaccin de pfizer en l'espace de 108
jours écoutez la réaction de l'avocat de
cette organisation c'est une grande
victoire pour la transparence et cela
supprime la mainmise des autorités
sanitaires fédérales sur les données
nécessaires pour les scientifiques
indépendants afin d'offrir des solutions
sur des problèmes importants avec le
programme actuel de vaccination des
problèmes tels que le déclin de
l'immunité des variants échappant à
l'immunité ou comme la cdc l'a confirmé
le fait que les vaccins ne n'empêche pas
la transmission life billets devraient
donc déjà publié douze mille pages d'ici
la fin du mois de janvier est une autre
étape a été fixé par ce tribunal d'ici
la fin du mois de mars l' agence
américaine d médicament devra publier
une première salve de documents de 55
mille pages